tesla has over 1 million cyber truck
reservations unofficial tally says fox
business an ongoing unofficial crowd
source
tally managed by salsa fan tesla fans
estimates that over 1 million people
have put down the hundred dollars
he's one of them
less than a week after the cyber trucks
reveal in november 2019 llamas claimed
that the company had received 250 000
reservations must said that he estimates
output by cyber trucks texas
factory will be quarter million to 300
000 annually the first cyber truck
deliveries are scheduled to happen in
the end of 2021 according to musk
but high volume production won't begin
until next year the starting price for
the pickup was 39
900 for a rear wheel
drive model but that configuration won't
be available until 2022 the tally
suggests that just seven and a half
percent of the reservation holders
have chosen it while the forty nine
thousand nine hundred dollars and the
sixty nine thousand nine hundred dollar
dual
and tri-motor models currently make up
and 44 and a half percent of the milks
respectively
a million orders that's insane
what is a million times forty thousand
dollars guy and you're one of them
i'm one of them what i understand i'm
one of them yeah i i
i only need about another 199 999 to go
and i got it
but i got my i got the reserves 40
billion right there you got to buy a
ticket
40 billion 40 billion right there if
they only bought it
at the model thirty nine thousand
dollars okay if they buy it at the 50
that's 50 billion you're talking about a
50 billion auto check right there
okay 50 billion dollar check right there
too
elon musk was good at business i know
that you're one of the guys who put down
100 bucks
refundable 100 walk us through your
process how you my your mindset honestly
man i'm just a massive elon musk fan
and uh you know i support uh you know he
supports me culturally and i support him
financially that that's the
truth mad at him about all the crypto
ups and downs
he put he put bitcoin on sale for me man
like i'm not mad at him at all anybody
who's really into crypto is
anybody who's actually been doing this
for a long time we've
we've become you know you cannot kill
that which is already dead we've become
numb to the dips brother you know what
i'm saying so
we don't panic and sell anymore we look
at a big dip like this and we say oh
it's on sale you know what i'm saying
like
i'm trying i was trying to get sam to to
give me next week's check early this
week so i can go blow it all on
on bitcoin but uh i i don't think i
don't think jen signed off on that but
the
uh i don't think she signed off on that
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye